peut-être juste une question
supplémentaire est-ce que vous avez lu
l'appel aujourd'hui de la Quinzaine
d'élus socialistes publié dans Le
Parisien je l'ai lu rapidement non je ne
l'ai pas lu mais si vous vou et ben on
va en parler très brièvement d'ailleurs
avec Jean-François je pardon
Jean-Philippe Maly que nous avons en
ligne excusez-moi Jean-Philippe Maly
vous êtes en ligne avec nous et député
de cette 11e circonscription député
socialiste vous faites partie des
cignataires vous demandez à François
Hollande de je cite remettre l'agenda
économique et sociale en tête des
priorités de l'action gouvernementale et
d'instaurer la grande réforme fiscale
redistributive annoncé par le président
François Hollande durant la campagne
Jean-Philippe my pourquoi cet appel
aujourd'hui à travers la presse au chef
de
l'État il nous semblait bonjour
d'abordour
jeilippe nous avons Arnaud Richard
effectivement avec nous sur le plateau
bonjour bonjour chers chers collègu tu
vas bienputé très bien je te remercie
chers collègue député des des Yvelines
que l'on tout à fait que je rencontre
régulièrement tout à fait voilà alors ce
qui concerne cet appel voilà pourquoi
interpeller aujourd'hui par voie de
presse le président la République oh
simplement vous savez on euh c'est dans
la la suite le prolongement euh d'un
d'un appel qui avait donné lieu
d'ailleurs un ouvrage un livre plaédoyé
pour une gauche populaire qui avait été
publié avant les élections
présidentielles en réaction vous savez à
à une note qui avait été publiée par
Terranova euh et qui disait bon ben
voilà il faut que le que la gauche se se
se sur les classes moyennes et moyennes
supérieures nous nous disons ces députés
là nous disons non la priorité quand on
est de gauche c'est de de s'intéresser
aux classes populaires et aux classes
moyennes
euh le chômage la lutte contre le
chômage pour vous ce n'est pas le cas
actuellement le le gouvernement ne fait
pas ce qu'il faut en tout cas les les
discussions les débats qui pent ne sont
pas vraiment sur ces ces questions là je
pense par exemple au mariage pour tous
non alors voilà moi je dirais pas ça
franchement on a voté le budget on
s'inscrit dans la majorité on soutient
évidemment le gouvernement et il s'agit
pas pour nous de condamner François
Holland il s'agit simplement de dire à
l'issue de cette de cette phase qui a vu
le vote du du budget 2013 et où il y a
eu quand même des choses des choses
importantes qui ont été qui ont été voté
il s'agit de dire aussi mais il faut
aller plus loin il ne faut pas que que
que l'on baisse la garde certainement
qu'on plus loin sur la lutte contre les
inégalités
sociales la lutte contre le chômage et
que les réformes sociétales vous me
parlez du du mariage des homosexuels
dont on parle beaucoup dont on parle
beaucoup trop ne doit pas masquer ce qui
pour nous est l'essentiel qui est le
social il y a tout même quelque chose de
particulier vous la gauche on est plutôt
la gauche sociale si vous voulez que que
sociétale mais il y a tout même quelque
chose de particulier vous êtes à la base
le suppléant de Benoît amont qui est
aujourd'hui ministre qui siège au
conseil des ministres il est au
gouvernement et pour autant vous vous
inscrivez pas en oppos oppition mais
vous interpellez le gouvernement est-ce
que passer par benoî amont par exemple
n'aurait pas été aussi la solution de
régler ces affaires aussi en interne non
mais vous savez on n'est pas en
opposition au gouvernement hein c'est
tout simplement c'est un appel on on se
situe vraiment pas en opposition puisque
nos votes le le le montre au Parlement
on soutient vraiment le l'action du
gouvernement il s'agit simplement de
dire voilà il faut aller plus loin il y
a eu des choses qui ont été promises
également pendant la campagne des
présidentielles hein par exemple
fusionner fusionner la CSG et l'impôt
sur le revenu on on part du principe que
la fiscalité pour nous c'est quand même
euh le domaine important de l'État qui
permet une redistribution euh c'est par
la fiscalité que que l'État peut peut
lutter contre les inégalités aujourd'hui
la fiscalité je vous parle même pas de
la fiscalité locale mais la fiscalité de
façon générale plus personne n comprend
rien elle est opaque ce qui ce qui
d'ailleurs cette opacité cette
complexité euh provoque
une crise de légitimité hein les
Français et à juste titre euh ne ne ne
comprenant plus ce qu'ils payent mett en
cause la fiscalité donc on appelle de
nos vux une une réforme qui tende à une
à une plus grande simplicité une plus
grande clarté et une meilleure
progressivité effectivement le
l'engagement que vous mentionnez c'était
le l'engagement numéro 14 de de François
Hollande pendant la campagne de
fusionner l'impôt sur le revenu et la
CSG pour simplifier un petit peu et puis
rendre progressif ces différents
prélèvement un dernier mot puisque nous
avons en ligne JeanPhilippe ce weekend
des jeunes appartenant à l'UMP dans
votre circonscription la 11e ont décidé
de vous faire parvenir un ballon de
football et un maillon un maillot
également à votre nom afin de rebondir
sur une séquence diffusée lors d'un
reportage de 66 minutes sur M6 le 9
décembre on peut voir avia Souli et
d'autres députés du Parti socialiste
dont vous discutez sur la façon dont on
pouvait obtenir c'était en pleine séance
à l'Assemblée des billets gratuits pour
le Stade de France cette séance cette
petite séquence se retrouve d'ailleurs
sur internet alors je vais pas vous
demander si vous avez déjà reçu ce
ballon et ce maillot mais en tout cas
quelle réponse vous leur apportez il
vous interpelle et ils nous disent un
député doit se montrer exemplaire et là
ça n'a pas été le cas bah écoutez moi je
je je vous réponds simplement regardez
la vidéo il se trouve que je suis à côté
de ce député de Marseille
aviassouli qui est à Marseille très
populaire il était le journaliste qui
commentait tous les tous les matchs de
l'OM bon voilà les choses ont fait que
je suis à côté de ce député et donc je
vous demande puisque vous êtes
journaliste vous faites sérieusement
votre métier regardez la vidéo et vous
verrez qui parle de ces places de
football et nous avons vu effectivement
cette séquence vidéo et pour des raisons
de droit on peut pas la la diffuser
aussi simplement que ça mais
effectivement on a vu cette séquence
mais en tout cas c'est la réponse que
vous leur faites puisque vous vous
interpelle sur ce pointl je ne me sens
pas concerné par ce qu'il me dis c'est
surtout ça quoi je ne suis absolument
pas concerné par par
ça regardz la vidéo euh je je ne parle
pas de ces places de football et on r
vooit donc les téléspectateurs à cette
séance C peties séquen lors d'une séance
à l'Assemblée nationale merci
Jean-Philippe my député PS de la 11e
circonscription d'avoir été avec nous
merci donc à Arnaud Richard député de la
7e pour évoquer le lancement de l'UDI et
puis toujours en politique on retiendra
également aujourd'hui que Pierre
sélincour Le Maire du Parti communiste
français à La Verrière pendant 29 ans et
qui cette année a passé la main à son
adjoint Alain ajage vient d'obtenir le
titre de maire honoraire une distinction
décernée lors du conseil municipal du 14
décembre les villes ont obligation avant
le 31 décembre de se regrouper entre
elles un schéma de coopération
intercommunale a été arrêté il fixe les
périmètres de ces nouvelles communautés
d'agglomération les
explications d'ici au 31 décembre la
notion de ville comme on la connaît ne
va plus exister les communes doivent se
regrouper à l'instar de ce qui existe
depuis 40 ans dans l'agglomération
cinquantinoise cela a fait l'objet
d'apre discussion entre les élus et la
commission départementale de coopération
intercommunale a arrêté son périmètre en
ce qui concerne la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans niveline pas
d'évolution du périmètre pas de commune
entrante ni de villees sortante la
casquie reste au nombre de 7 morpa et
coignère feront une intercommunalité à
deux un moment morpa avait souhaité
intégrer l'agglomération cinquantinoise
notamment par la voix de son premier
adjoint Pierre Le guerinel et coignère
avait évoqué un rapprochement de son
côté vers la communauté d'agglomération
de la Haute Vallée de Chevreuse mais
finalement il n'en sera rien plaisir les
clés sousbois et Villepreux se
regroupent un trio qui devra trouver son
harmonie car la sol avait été rejeté en
son temps par l'ancien maire P de
plaisir Joë rot estimant qu'il
s'agissait d'une erreur et du côté des
clés sousbois on avait clairement
affiché sa préférence pour Versailles
Grand Parc voire pour
50 an en Yveline mais rien n'est
définitivement acté la loi du 29 février
2011 permet de faire évoluer ses
périmètres avec une clause dite de
revoyure en 2015 ce sera donc un des
enjeux des prochaines élections
municipales de mars 2014